there it is from Tim Urban's weight but
why
blogger which are a problem
it's fascinating how it originates in
Marxism goes down the tree to critical
theory this is the best book since the
2020 cynical theories by Helen pluck
Rose and James Lindsay on this topic in
my opinion and you have he talks about
social justice fundamentalism at one end
and liberal social justice I think you
and I I think everybody in this room
frankly falls on the side of liberal
social justice not equality of outcome
equality of opportunity not using race
to divide but being what what is now a
microaggression colorblind to people we
make those judgments I do think that
there's a fundamental core tenant or
there are fundamental core tenets of the
ideology and so racism is everywhere
it's baked into the system there's
whiteness but your privilege seeks to
preserve itself I mean etc etc and that
is a component of what wokeness is but
it's also just when I when I try to
Envision wokeness as an object it is
like a Jackson Pollock painting yeah it
is but that's because wokeness isn't
ideology it is it is not this thing
these things uh they frustrate me when I
see and and I think this is this this
chart is probably correct uh I'm you
know going from post-modernism down and
critical race Theory and
intersectionality but it applies an
academic world view into the modern
problem which has already been shown by
mult uh numerous data points including
there was the Zach Roberts Lexus Nexus
Twitter threat from a few years ago that
all around the same time everywhere in
the world the same thing happened where
there was a massive spike in the same
Concepts ideas words and what likely
happened is and I'll put it this way the
reason why I don't believe we're dealing
with an ideal ideology of the left we're
dealing with algorithmic corruption is
that Jack Dorsey was not woke until he
started eating the own refuse of his own
social media platform okay so can we
spend some time on this because I think
that's really important okay so this is
the frame that I suggest thinking about
this at the top you have Theory
below that you have institutions and
downstream from that you have
individuals beliefs so 2017 we had this
almost this exact conversation yeah a
very heated debate I would call it
Lively I thought it was great no I
thought it was great too I thought it
was fantastic with with James and Helen
in the room so
so at the level of theory you have what
we tried to do with so-called squared if
the grievance studies hoax we tried to
undermine the theory we tried to show
that it's bogus we tried to attack it
what Reid and I are going around the
world doing Street epistemology is to
show so that it goes from the theory to
the institutions the institutions to the
people the institutions the academies
K-12 and we can talk about that more
than happy to talk about that our
academic institutions you get promoted
and tenure based upon the papers you you
write usually seven papers in seven
years unless you you write something
that's morally fashionable it's very
difficult to get published and we're
going to do the University of San
Francisco story I hope because I think
that this encapsulates it perfectly
educational administrators themselves
participate in the ideology so there's a
structure
and so so when you say algorithms I want
to say two things that are important
about this the woke people occupy the
very so they get their degree five six
seven years later they go out they
become administrators they become
managers et cetera they bring the
madness that they took with them that
they think it's true based upon what
they perceive to be legitimate bodies of
literature microaggressions trigger
warnings safe spaces belonging Equity
all this nonsense they take that with
them and they institutionalize that we
can cover it if you want but it's a
reverse Trojan Horse Martin Bailey we
can cover that so now to get to your
point about the algorithms yes you are
correct but the algorithms themselves
wouldn't even make sense unless you
understood that model like this doesn't
come ex-niolo like Mana from heaven
right so it comes at a very specific
place that's right I think that
institutions include social media
networks now hold on the first uh one of
the first big political Trends was
probably Loose Change 911 which was
certainly not within the confines of
this Academia and the Ron Paul
Revolution which was absolutely not in
the confines of this Academia what what
happens is
you see what I believe it is that humans
have tendencies
uh rage make someone more likely to
share something than any other emotion
anger and I always shout out cgp's gray
cgp Gray's video this video will make
you angry and he explains this and he
was like it's really great he's like
this group is talking about the other
group the other group's talking about
this group they're actually talking to
each other they're talking about each
other and he's like trust me I am not
talking about your group
so what I see here is yes the ideologies
of the left do exist and they do have a
degree of prominence among the modern
left today but there's also I don't know
how many how many ideologies exist 100
000 countless Millions countless so why
is it that this is the one I think the
issue is that's a genealogical question
that I that I could answer but I I don't
think uh uh the chart the chart actually
answers that but right but this chart
that omits every other ideology and the
path that's taken and it's degree of
prominence but every other ideology
isn't the dominant moral Orthodoxy now
this is the dominant moral Orthodoxy we
see it everywhere and it's because of
social media algorithms not because of
University okay okay so that's the
question that's question why are the
social media algorithms catering to the
moral Orthodoxy they they're so very
simply put advertisers fund moral
Orthodoxy before wokeness took over how
did this begin first we had in what was
it what year was it Luke 2008 2009 the
Ron Paul Revolution right around yep
you're starting to see the emergence of
moral of of moralizing through social
media with people listening to Ron
Paul's message and it resonating to the
point where they were going around
swiping stickers everywhere
anti-intervention sound currency a lot
of really really awesome things that I
completely agree with today but
eventually
these social media platforms started to
adopt algorithms that would show you
more of what you engaged with two things
happen people people are more likely to
share something that makes them angry
and advertisers are less likely to
advertise on something that's morally
objectionable in modern culture at the
time 2008 we find racism to be
objectionable so a big Advertiser says I
don't want my product on racist content
you know we we okay so you just smuggled
something in there we find it to be
objectionable because
this is morally fashionable like this is
what's morally fashionable today but
this was true
yeah I guess the the main wokeness
really kicked in 2012 2010 so 2008 I
would give its pre-wokeness but you're
talking in that case you're talking
about kind of tribalism right you're not
talking about the algorithms themselves
do they feed outrage for sure yes yeah
for sure every single thing you've said
is true
and it's I don't mean to use a big word
but it's the only word to describe it's
covariant like both of those variables
act upon each other at the same time to
enforce the dominant moral Orthodoxy
even more than it was in the first place
so what's happening is this is why I say
that the problem is not the ideology the
ideologies existed for a long time the
ideology is a component of the problem
the problem is we are in a feedback loop
of algorithms quadrupling upon
quadrupling our problem it's exponential
growth so so the example of this I give
is 2008 it starts with the viral Ron
Paul Revolution which is a good thing
then you start to see my favorite
example is mic.com which started off as
a website exploiting this and they were
producing libertarian content however
within that libertarian content was
anti-police brutality content because
Libertarians didn't like that either
there was also Second Amendment audits
that were going viral where people were
alike the cop stopped me and you get
these videos of people challenging
police officers then people start adding
in a racial component why because they
start putting up videos of police
brutality against black people
these videos start getting and get start
getting uh just plastered all over
Facebook because it makes money at one
point a website that was dedicated to
nothing but police brutality videos was
the 400th most viewed website in the
world I'm not going to say what website
that was and uh they were paying their
writers an exorbitant amount of money
and all they did was post videos of
police brutality this starts fracturing
the minds of 10 year olds in 2010 who
are now 23 year olds who are voting in
this election whose entire world view
has been built upon a machine that
started with libertarian Advanced into a
so here's what happens when Libertarians
are sharing anti-police content and
they're getting a lot of views because
people don't like Injustice it is the is
the epitome of Injustice when a cop
violates our rights like that's that's
the op that's supposed to be upholding
the law then you add in a racial
component and now you have an
exponential growth the people who hate
racism and the people who like who hate
police brutality everyone's seeing it
and everyone's sharing it then mike.com
shifts its business model and says this
gets more views let's do more of this
instead the company then slowly rather
exponentially rapidly shifts into a woke
social justice company but here's the
thing when this happened we didn't have
the word woke any sort of it it was it
was here and there what was the word
intersectional feminist which then gave
rise to social justice and social
justice Warriors I mean at first it was
feminism then it was intersectional
feminism then the then the sjw then we
ended up with the complaints about
critical race Theory then people pointed
out actually critical gender theories in
there too and now it's woke what we're
seeing is a feedback loop of social
media algorithms funneling refuse back
into the mouths of people and what I
would only describe as a human centipede
of ideology just to clarify would you
say that woke is the way that the
ideology is funneled
so when people say what does woke even
mean okay well when when the average
person describes woke they may mean a
bunch of different things but the one
unifying factor is they're referring to
the modern left liberal Orthodoxy that
was created by social media algorithms
and the example I give is you
Ukraine war is the is the easiest way to
understand this why is it that Hassan
will be like here are these things
that I believe trans rights and then
also I also am for war in Ukraine and
you're like what did these things have
to do with each other and why is it that
this individual has no principles it's
just
he just follows the Orthodoxy you think
there's a woke on the on the other side
of the coin like for people right wing
conversion but it's so small and there's
no institutional power behind it I find
it to be negligible but it could become
it could become a problem if it were let
I think it was white nationalism yeah I
think that the anti-woke people are
starting to use some of the tools of the
wolf now so it's and I want someone to
come back to what you said because I
think it's important uh you know
cancellation or not having conversations
with people with whom they disagree so I
think that they're adopting the tools to
buttress the ideology
so this is both a very complicated
problem and a non-complicated problem so
I don't mean to muddy the waters too
much but I do want to say this because
it's been really bumming me out so I
read a piece in the epistemology of
democracy it was about by Keith stanovic
it was about my side bias and my side
bias this will horrify you and hear it
but my side bias is exactly what you
think it would be my side is right your
side is wrong but this the the article
or the chapter in the book argued that
there's literally nothing you can do to
overcome my advice no training no
education nothing but when you combine
that
um that research chapter with what you
just said not only can you not do
there's no amount of Education that can
get over my side by us you're now
talking the algorithm being held hostage
to the algorithm yes
by the humans so even if you're right so
even if there weren't the case that
you're being held hostage by the
algorithm you're still suffering you
know this my side bias thing no training
no education Etc you just can't so what
are you gonna do so that is I think what
is often missing in these conversations
would I just like to throw in there we
know there's a problem we've been
talking you and I have been talking for
years we know this is a problem and I
think when people are hungry for now is
what are we going to do about it what's
the sign of Alex you said one you said
one thing right we're going to stop
donating to Alma Mater we're going to
stop buying you know we're going to vote
with our dollars if you will but I think
what would be helpful I think to a lot
of your viewers is ending every one of
these sessions these conversations with
what are you going to do about like
empowering them to do something and so
obviously that's why I wanted to lead
with the Anheuser-Busch story because it
seems like this is particularly
effective let me tell you I've got these
tweets that I love to tweet where I say
something like sterilize your children
to prevent overpopulation right it's a
joke right or I'll say something about
uh leftists will abort their children or
sterilize their children
and then I had one tweet where I said
and this is a good thing because it
stops overpopulation and humans are
causing climate change not one time has
any publication ever criticized me or
written about those tweets
yet when I say don't buy beer I get 500
articles saying far right fascist
outraged whiny loser because you can
tell what's working they don't want to
bring up the fact that they're aborting
their kids and sterilizing them because
that's bad for them in the long run but
if they highlight that they have to
point out the things we're promoting are
detrimental and deleterious to our
ideology and then when I say something
like don't buy beer they're like quick
we got to put a stop on stop to that not
only is it affecting our ad our
potential sales because we're sponsored
by this company
but there's there's there's truth the
fact that if Budweiser sales do drop and
they are forced to apologize
that will be a major shift in the
culture War the moment a massive
multinational corporation says we are
sorry for being woke woke people will
lose their minds because that means that
we're sorry we made a genuine mistake we
wish we hadn't done it we have we'd like
to get you back and then and that's and
and real quick Netflix never apologized
for Cuties and they still have big mouth
but when they started getting rid of
some of the woke uh shows and stuff they
had and they talked about it they saw a
subscriber increase so they're probably
learning an important lesson but the
apology is everything you said earlier
real quick just one last point
antifa uses violence and the far left
uses violence and in the Summer of Love
they got away with it because they have
law enforcement to a certain degree on
their side either because police are too
feckless or the DA's are bought and paid
for so these big companies as I've long
stated do not fear Dave Rubin classical
liberals showing up with pitchforks they
do fear antifa who do it and get away
with it if Budweiser is willing to make
an apology to all of us for sponsoring
Dylan Mulvaney that means they are
saying the threat of physical force from
antifa is not as scary as us actually
going out of business yeah and I want to
I want to add to that and I want to just
say that the people listening to this
one of the things that I've seen over
and over again is people are very afraid
to piss off the far left my comment to
you is they already hate you they
already hate you because you're going to
say something are not toe the line
perfectly do not be afraid of these
people do not be held hostage to them be
based also the cartels and Islam don't
be held a hostage to violent extremists
of any kind no offense people not Islam
at all but I mean you know what's his
name um Richard Dawkins was afraid to
even criticize or talk about it and it's
really sad because every manager should
be criticized shout out to Stephen
Crowder potentially one of the most
Fearless guys who's constantly making
jokes and saying F you to all of these
extremists were telling them to shut up
you said earlier how it could these
things could cause people to lose their
minds these far left and you were saying
this my side bonus I actually jokingly
said psychedelics but like I think being
able to clear your mind helps you see
the the danger of your side like if it
means that recording yourself on video
uploading it and watching yourself say
it and having no choice but to accept
that's what you are you'll see what you
did wrong thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time